my name is sam bates i'm a koi pond
specialist at grassroots ponded garden
my family's business and today i'm going
to be showing you how we do a deep
cleaning on koi ponds
koi ponds can get pretty dirty and this
is for a number of different reasons one
of which at least here in michigan where
we are from we have a lot of deciduous
trees that drop leaves into the pond
they then break down that organic matter
can turn the water either brown or
sometimes it helps make it green this
one over here is what we call carpet
algae it's very very difficult to get
off the bottom and the sides of the
liner but it's actually beneficial to a
pond to have the carpet algae this
typically comes with age the carpet
algae can get as long as shag carpet and
also it houses bacteria and acts as
another biological filtration system
within your pond that you didn't even
have to pay for
when we are removing koi from ponds we
use what's called a sock net it's very
silky smooth so it's very delicate on
the fish and it has two open ends which
makes it easy to hold and the fish can't
escape and also you can release the fish
through the bottom or the back side of
the net so the fish really doesn't
undergo much stress during the
transportation process when we're
cleaning koi ponds we keep the koi
goldfish frogs and such in separate
collapsible containers they hold five to
six hundred gallons of water and leaves
plenty of room for the fish to hang out
ponds that are over taken with algae
whether it be microscopic algae which
causes green water or string algae
getting a deep clean to the very bottom
could be a good restart
this pond here represents what we
typically will find when it comes
springtime and time to open up a koi
pond the water is green that is the
suspended algae the ammonia breakdown
from any organic matter whether that be
sadly maybe a fish that passed away or
it can be tannins in the water which
leech from leaves pine cones sticks
anything like that and these things
should be cleaned out really once a year
we use this hose connected to typically
a 6 000 gallon per hour pump that we
submerge at the bottom of the pond to
remove the water
now where does the water go well it
really depends on where we're at
sometimes it goes to their yard
sometimes it goes out to the road it
really all just depends
some ponds only need to get pumped out
once those are the easiest and then
others it can be anywhere from two to a
dozen times when ponds are full of
gravel at the bottom you have to rinse
in between the gravel and you'll often
find a lot of mud and debris that's
hidden to your eye but we try to remove
it just because it can still affect with
water chemistry typically when cleaning
ponds we find all sorts of stuff but the
regular things that we find are
bullfrogs green frogs toads lots of
toads and we also find dragonfly larvae
turtles
in all of this mucky stuff that we find
at the bottom of ponds it ranges from
really a cocktail of tree leaves sorts
of needles and sticks and mostly fish
waste
and it smells
awful there's really no other way to put
it the
smell actually varies by pond
some
barely smell
and then some
make you just want to run away but you
have to go through it and you have to
get it out this pond was so large in
surface area with a flat bottom to where
we couldn't rinse everything to one end
we're using a squeegee to actually
remove all of the excess water and
debris that is stuck in the bottom of
the pond on their carpet algae
[Music]
the rock the liner can be covered in
string algae
if your lawnmower is aiming in the wrong
direction and it's kicking grass
clippings into the pond or sometimes
even sprays like herbicides or
pesticides can raise the ammonia levels
in the pond and that can cause just a
whole world of issues causing algae and
even killing some of the pets within the
system so you get as close as you can
with the right bit on the power washer
and you remove the algae then you rinse
it to the bottom and then we use a shop
vac to clean up all of the sludge and
nasty stuff that we left at the bottom
as well as vacuuming out the skimmers
and the filters
it's important to clean out the bottom
of the filtration system because this is
where all of the heavy sludge and fish
waste particularly like to set and stay
stagnant when refilling ponds after a
deep cleaning uh we typically just use
the client's garden hose and we will run
it until we have enough water for the
fish to be released we add dechlorinator
usually right at the beginning and we
will aerate the pond to ensure that the
dechlorinator has went thoroughly
through the existing water before we
release the fish we make sure that the
water is splashing into the pond opposed
to just filling from the bottom and
staying fairly stagnant creating those
bubbles helps push that chlorine out of
the system and gas off to make it
healthy for the fish
this bag of what looks to be dirty water
is actually beneficial bacteria that
helps break down fish waste and helps
with pond clarity throughout the season
this is something that we add weekly and
our clients often ask what is that bag
of brown water and what's in it all i
can tell them is it's bacteria because
that's my grandfather and my father's
secret recipe for years so i can't let
you in on that
[Music]
[Music]
you